attending the dlrs summer school would
give me more of an exposure to all the
different fields of uh machine learning
and deep learning and also like
networking I met so many people from
across the globe and hopefully some
collaborations come out of
[Music]
it it gives you a really focused
introduction to some of the key
Technologies but also a relatively broad
perspective on the different
applications
I found the summer school really helpful
because you could get a lot of
information which helps me in my future
research so in a relatively short amount
of time we've been able to really like
get a lot of content uh into the into
the 5 days and then there's been like
also some time for fun and socializing
outside of it which hopefully has been
productive and enjoyable you need to
learn about other fields you need to
make more connections it's it's a great
experience in my
opinion